New York Police are investigating a
deepening mystery surrounding the
suspicious deaths of two Saudi Arabians
sisters the bodies of 16 year old Tala
and 23 year old Rotana Ferrer were
discovered bound together last week the
sisters lived in Northern Virginia
Jericka Duncan is along the Hudson River
in New York where their remains were
found Jericho good morning good morning
those sisters were reported missing on
September 12th from Fairfax Virginia
investigators are now trying to piece
together how they got from Fairfax
Virginia to New York City and ultimately
they want to know what happened that led
them to end up here behind me along the
Hudson River it's scary it's supposed to
be the good neighborhoods where you
should feel safe the lifeless bodies of
Tala and Ratana Faria were found on a
rocky pier in New York City last
Wednesday
police say the sisters were bound
together at their ankles and waist with
duct tape we are out to get justice for
those two girls and to find out exactly
what happened what led them to be
recovered in the water
the NYPD does not get know if this is a
homicide or suicide they're also having
a tough time tracking where the sisters
were in the weeks leading up to their
deaths no cell phones or social media
accounts were recovered detectives have
been down in Virginia they've conducted
a number of interviews in Virginia
including members of the immediate
family as well as tawa and Ratana moved
to the u.s. from Saudi Arabia with their
mother in 2015
settling in Fairfax Virginia and NYPD's
source tells CBS News that their mother
told police she received a call from the
Saudi government in October telling the
family they had to come back to Saudi
Arabia because the sisters had applied
for immigration asylum in the u.s. in a
statement the Saudi consulate general
said it will follow the case closely and
that the sisters were students
accompanying their brother in Washington
CBS News has learned that there is
evidence that shows the sisters were
alive when they entered the water
investigators hoping to learn the cause
of death once the toxicology reports are
released Jon Jericka Thank You
grizzly and
mmm-hmm the more you hear the more
bizarre it is right